(people shouting)
- I was shocked.
There is this guy lying on the ground
and he is not a danger to anyone.
He's just lying there
and two or three officers
are beating him with batons
and everybody's just standing around them.
Nothing is happening.
I mean, this was, for me,
the paradigmatic bad action.
How can you do that?
- [Narrator] It's a question at the heart
of many alleged police
misconduct incidents,
from the beating of Rodney King in 1991
to the choke-hold death
of Eric Garner in 2014,
and the killing of George Floyd in 2020.
Why did other officers not intervene?
- Back off.
- He's not responding.
- The ideal is really simple.
You stand up
and do something and sometimes
something very limited
to stop a fellow officer
from doing unnecessary harm to someone.
- [Narrator] Ervin Staub is a psychologist
who has studied the concept
of active bystandership.
He first applied it to policing
after the Rodney Kind beating.
Now it's the foundation of a new version
of active bystander police training,
created by Georgetown
University Law School's
Innovative Policing Program
called Active Bystandership
for Law Enforcement, or ABLE.
- What brings us here
today? The ABLE training.
- [Narrator] Since the
murder of George Floyd
during an arrest by Minneapolis police,
over 100 law enforcement agencies
across the US have signed
on for the training.
Teaching police officers to
intervene against one another
is a complicated mission.
- The tradition is that police officers
are supposed to help each other
and support each other no matter what.
So there is a very profound need
to change their culture.
- [Presenter] So we may
condense a little bit.
- It's family I guess
it's the simplest way
of putting it.
It is being an extended family.
There's loyalty to my squad,
loyalty to my subordinates, my detectives.
- One of the themes I've
already heard so far
this morning is loyalty.
We talked about when
the call comes, we go,
there's no questions.
- [Narrator] At a recent
training in New Jersey
for law enforcement
agencies across the state,
officers began tackling this challenge.
- We are loyal to one another.
You've got to be wiling
to have a hard conversation with somebody.
If you're loyal to them,
if you really care about them,
you are gonna have that integrity
and not just have that blind allegiance.
- [Officer] I think you need to be humble.
I think you need to learn.
I think the biggest problem
that we have right now
in all this shit that's been going on
is piss poor police training.
That's what it comes down to.
- [Narrator] The ABLE program seeks
to go beyond previous versions
of active bystander police training
by teaching officers
how to overcome the psychological
hurdles to intervening.
It's rooted in Staub's experience
as a child in the Holocaust.
(dramatic music)
- I was a six-year-old child in Hungary
at the time when about
450,000 Hungarian Jews
were pushed into train, cars,
taken to Auschwitz and most
of them immediately killed.
This woman who was taking care of us,
took me and my sister into hiding.
One thing that I learned
from life and also from research,
bystanders can be very powerful,
influencing other bystanders
and their behavior.
- Good morning, guys.
Can we line up for inspection?
- [Narrator] Sergeant
Anthony Lynn has been
with the Voorhees Township
New Jersey Police Department
for nine years.
- You wanna turn to the right.
(car indictor clicking)
- [Narrator] He and his
fellow officers recently
went through active bystander training.
- Everybody's human,
everybody has their moments
and sometimes you just need
to be reeled back a little bit
so that you understand
that it's not a situation
where you wanna be a snitch
or be labeled as a snitch
but you wanna make sure
that they get home safe,
we get home safe.
(dramatic music)
- If we've been honest with each other,
we don't like changing
law enforcement, right?
- [Narrator] The training seeks
to address cultural change
in a few key ways.
The leaders and chiefs of
agencies are trained first
and instructors are members
of the departments they train.
- Get the class to talk about it,
get the role players to talk about it.
How did you feel about that?
What tactics did you use?
- [Narrator] The
participants in this class
will train officers in their
respective departments.
- There's some officers
that they would interpret
that intervention as saying,
"You're incompetent, you can't handle it."
And you know, you need to
have a cultural component
that says, you know, that's okay.
It's okay to have somebody step in.
- We also train people to
accept the intervention.
So you are learning how to intervene,
first, in as limited way as possible.
And escalate as necessary
and how to accept training.
- It's a hot call, so a
lot of cops are showing.
Early in my career,
there was an occasion where we had arrest
and I'm escorting him back to one
of the patrol cars to transfer
him back to headquarters.
One of the senior
officers at the time kind
of stepped and grabbed
him, opened the door
and seemed like about to
basically slam the guy
in the door there.
Thankfully a senior officer was there
and kind of intervened and stepped in
but as I think back, I
should have said something
at that time.
It shouldn't had to take someone else
to step in to intervene.
(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] The program
also teaches officers
to look for allies when intervening.
- And you say to a fellow officer,
"This is bad, we should do something."
And then you jointly take action.
- [Narrator] The creators
of the ABLE program plan
to study data from participating agencies
to evaluate its effectiveness.
The impact of other versions
of active bystander training
has been inconclusive.
The New Orleans Police
Department reported a decrease
in civilian complaints
after participating in a previous version
of the training but those
results may have been influenced
by other reforms mandated by
the Department of Justice.
To have an impact, the challenge for Staub
and the ABLE program
is not just to show how to intervene
but to make it acceptable to intervene.
- We have the ability to shift the culture
within ourselves and we have
the ability to repair the trust
with the community.
We have to be able to protect ourselves
and sometimes pull somebody back
from potentially harming someone else
or harming themselves.
It seems to me like it's going
to be a very important tool going forward.